diese unglaublich cremige trüffelpasta
kannst du innerhalb von 5 Minuten kochen
ohne kochen zu können und ich sag dir
auch warum es gibt keine gute
fertigpasta deshalb habe ich eine
gemacht ich darf euch vorstellen Pasta
poesia authentische italienische Pasta
und Soße alles von italienischen
Herstellern alles aus italienischen
Zutaten ihr werdet gleich sehen das ist
einfach next level und ich bin unfassbar
stolz darauf so Cremer alteratfo gehen
wir eine Pfanne und wir geben direkt
einen Schluck Nudelwasser dazu das ist
alles was ihr machen müsst wenn ich das
Nudelwasser drin habe kann ich einmal
ein bisschen umrühren und es entsteht
eine wunderschöne cremige Soße die wir
noch mal kurz aufkochen die tatelle
brauchen 3 Minuten und sind jetzt fertig
auch diese Pasta ist wirklich kein
Vergleich zu dem was wir in Deutschland
haben jetzt haben wir unsere Pasta und
unsere Soße und wir verbinden das ganze
einfach guckt euch mal an wie unfassbar
cremig die wird mama mia ein Traum und
Parmesan gibt's natürlich auch dazu ich
verspreche euch ihr werdet pastapoesia
lieben und wenn ihr über alles Bescheid
wissen wollt dann schaut euch die Pasta
poesia Channels an sind verlinkt denn
das wollt ihr nicht verpassen